word got around about this great prank a  kid and I'm wonder if you've heard about  this he I'm sure you have this kid gave  his mother a picture of you and he  played this prank because he knows his  mom is very religious and his mom  assumed it was a picture of Jesus and  hung it on her wall and we actually have  the picture that he gave to her like  it's there's Jesus there for reference  just in case you know what Jesus is that  I love that there's someone who's like  in times of trouble going to a young  obi-wan yeah that is funny but I did I  actually played Jesus and you played  Jesus in last days in the desert you  played Jesus so we actually have photos  of you really playing Jesus and so you  you'd wonder why the kid just didn't use  that well maybe no that one that's Jesus  clearly lost you know know where he's  going here right Jesus would not simply  use the app  [Applause]